foreign
so I'm gonna do something I don't
normally do on this show
we had a caller who called in
and
um talked with Jenna
and then backed out
now when you hear the topic I don't
blame blame him
tough topic
but it left us in a lurch
um because we I mean Jenna schedules
these calls out uh in advance
and as we sat around talking about this
call we thought we're just going to go
ahead and do the call without the caller
it's that good
so here's the question that we got I'm
going to read the email in its entirety
uh Jenna printed out the entire email
for me and here's what it said
Ben you need to put some like dramatic
music at the beginning of this that can
be arranged excellent okay
so here's the question from Dean in
South Carolina
canceled at the last minute
how can I address or should I address
the topic of my wife's weight
[Music]
married for 13 years with one child
I love her but her weight is becoming an
issue
she's always too tired to do anything
she sits on the couch and plays games on
her phone our intimacy life our intimate
life is lacking she turns me down a lot
because she's too tired I ask her to go
to the gym and she's too tired she says
she wants to lose weight but then does
nothing about it I'm not a small guy but
I go to the gym five to six days a week
she refuses to go back I am concerned
for her health that is the email
ah
[Music]
so can we do this
can I ask the two women in the booth we
all participate in this
happily yes
should Dean address the topic of his
wife's weight
married for 13 years with one child
I think there is a way to do it yes okay
don't know that it's the way he's
currently doing it
I mean there is a legit concern for
somebody's Health well and so this
email's got like 15 different issues in
it right oh there are issues yes yes
Jenna when you first hear this what what
happens inside of your body
oh I don't like it no no no no okay why
not I don't like the way he keeps
calling her lazy I don't like the way
that he says I go to the gym five to six
times a week and not to mention we
talked about this before they have one
child so we don't know how recent that
was uh it could be she's going through
postpartum depression
um however I think yes address it but
like Kelly said not the way we think he
is so
here's a whole bunch this this tells me
this is a marriage in trouble and weight
is becoming
um the flash point of much bigger issues
so when I read this thing and again the
caller bailed out so we're just gonna go
with our side of this story here
um
married for 13 years with one child this
is a tough season for marriages
you're 13 that year from seven to ten
years and it extends out a little bit
that's a tough season for marriages
um so it's not uncommon for someone to
be in year 13 they've got a kid and they
start to ask themselves is this it is
this this what this is gonna be right
they answer that question a hundred
percent then a Time percent of the time
is it doesn't have to be any group can
change any marriage can change at any
moment and say we're gonna do something
totally different but
um I love her but
kind of like the old southern I don't
want to gossip but she's kinda
I said something so bad
you would have made me redo that so I
didn't say it I don't want to say
anything ugly about her but bless her
heart bless her heart
she makes out with lots of boys right
like anytime you say the word but I love
her butt you just just throw I love her
out the window it doesn't count so her
weight is becoming an issue
then he transitions to she's too tired
to do anything she sits on the couch and
couch and plays games on her phone then
he says we're not having sex and then
she says she rejects me a lot which is
different than we're not having sex she
rejects me a lot because she's too tired
I asked her to go to the gym and she's
too tired she doesn't want to go work
out with you Beefcake 2000 right so
there's a couple things here I want to
start with the obvious I have a friend I
don't even call him a friend I got a guy
that I know
um who gets home from work walks in the
front door and heads straight for the
refrigerator grabs a beer goes and sits
on the couch and turns the TV on and
does not move the rest of the night
period does it if there's no food being
brought to him he will just pull out his
phone and order it
I've known this dude to order a single
Jimmy John sandwich to his house just
for him he's got kids
that guy is lazy
lazy
he's probably going through a bunch of
crap and all that he's got depressed
whatever whatever
that is lazy there are people like that
in the world
that may be the case here maybe
but this wife's not on the phone so I'm
gonna go with probably not
followed up with number two
um
she's too tired to do anything
hey husband maybe ask
not in the middle of a conver of a
heated fight not when she's sitting on
the couch looking half asleep but on a
date on a Saturday morning
hey you look so exhausted
like I want to walk through our live the
life that we lead together and I want to
find things that I can take off your
plate I want to be a better contributor
on this house and your first thought
might be I work all day I don't give a
crap
what can I do to help in this season
right how can I help everybody be less
tired right
um
Kelly Jenny y'all pitch in any moment
here the next one is
um our sex life is lacking she turns me
down a lot because she's too tired
Maybe
or maybe I'm too tired is a way to keep
her you off of her
for any number of reasons and I will
also say if she's put weight on she's
well aware
hey you've put on a bunch of weight and
they're like what no way I didn't notice
and so she may not feel very attractive
right now
because that's a legit thing I
understand I understand that she may not
feel attractive and saying I want you to
come have sex with me is not a way to
make somebody feel attractive right
working really hard to let somebody
experience that they are beautiful
is totally different okay
um
I don't know how long I have to keep
saying this
but men
um
trying to tell your wife how much you go
to the gym
as the precursor to get her to go to the
gym
it's one of the dumbest things you can
do
because trust me she already knows how
much he goes to the gym because chances
are she's home by herself dealing with
everything while he goes to the gym what
are you saying Jenna I get to see you
lightened up in there man yeah no that
would put me off
um also I just realized too at the end
it says she refuses to to go back so in
my mind she's gone to the gym with him
before there's a reason now she's not
going with you more than yeah yeah
and so
husbands are often guilty of saying
let's go to the gym and wife goes and
then he gives her the the Mind pump
anabolic workout program that's about an
hour and 20 minutes and she's never
lifted before and go like just how you
do squats and this is how you do split
squats and she's like I don't I don't
feel comfortable in here it's holding
everyone's looking at me I'm I like what
are we doing the whole thing's awkward
and awful and the next day she's so sore
that she can't breathe and then he's
snapped into a Slim Jim and she's like
I'm not going back
versus
hey I'd love to go to the gym you want
to go to the gym with me I've got my
whole workout thing I'm gonna do and
asking is there anything I can help you
with
and she can say nope
or she can say I just don't even know
how those things work I don't know what
to do in there I feel awkward and weird
cool I'm gonna hire let's hire a
personal trainer for three or four times
you can go by yourself you can go on
Saturday mornings but nobody's there or
you can go at 10 A.M when nobody's there
right and we'll get we'll pay for child
care whatever but sit down and have that
conversation versus just handing a
workout and being like go get em right
totally different program yeah or even
like just start like instead of maybe
jumping right to the gym like hey why
don't we start going for like a walk
let's go for a while just getting
outside and go being together maybe even
having that time together of just you
and her and having conversation she'll
open up more because chances are she's
probably dealing with stuff that she's
not talking to him about because his
answer is it up let's go and that's
not a great answer most of the time
Ashley to people we love
and I don't know why this is
it's one of the great mysteries of our
world but
um
I have a PhD in counseling you know who
I don't give counseling advice to my
wife
did you know my wife is kind of putting
her on blast a little bit it's kind of
funny but she doesn't listen to the show
um
she explained to me a few months ago
this new stuff she had learned about how
trauma Works through its body it work
Works through a human body and how it
gets lodged up in the nervous system and
she kind of walked me through this
and I said
I wrote a book on trauma called own your
past change your future that
I think bought you a car and she was
like yeah but like this is what I'm
trying to explain and I at that moment I
just knew I knew because I've been
married for 20 years and I love her and
I know I just let her teach me about it
and
that was awesome
and there was nothing about winning and
there was nothing about why haven't you
read my book and what because she
listens to all those stories for she's
listening all stories forever she lived
many of those stories and it's probably
not good for her mental and emotional
health to go read that them again but
all to say is
handings like brow beating somebody into
an exercise program is never helpful
maybe sitting down and saying hey I go
to the gym five to six days a week
I'm gonna start going three
which gives me three more days it's a
couple of hours a day
between the drive there the workout and
the drive back to go all in plugging
into this household how can I help
because I want you to know how much I
love you I want you to feel beautiful
I want you to feel like you've got some
capacity to breathe and do some things
that you want to do
and it's also fair to say I feel like
I'm losing you to your phone
that's different than you're always on
your phone but saying
I'm losing you to your phone I'm losing
you to the couch I'm losing you to the
television set
and I feel like you're having an affair
with with an electronic device
I miss you
am I hard to be around am I hard to be
with
I know right when I said having an
affair with electronic device Kelly
started laughing so there you go
just no no
so asking you can ask y'all one more
question sure so
is there ever a place for your husbands
to sit across the table and say
I'm struggling with being attracted to
you right now or you've put on a whole
bunch of weight in the last year or two
and I'm concerned for your health
I am struggling with attraction
I'm struggling with watching the person
I love how she feels about herself is
there ever a place for that in your
opinion definitely yeah
um Jen and I had this conversation early
and we have different answers but I
would have agreed with her when I was
her age but now here I am a couple years
later and um definitely there's a place
for that because there's
it doesn't mean you love me any less it
probably means you love me more than I
think you do because you're willing to
talk to me about this but yes
attraction's a real thing
and and there's a to me it comes down to
the way you do it and the reason you do
it the reason is the most important is
because I love you so much and I want us
to have this crazy sex life and I I love
I I want to want you kind of thing and
that that says something man because
that's going to be a big motivator for
me I think you're beautiful I love you
and I want you to be healthier because I
know also when you feel better and
you're healthier you're more engaged
there's a lot of ways to do it that are
appropriate and okay yeah hard yeah it's
going to be hard there's no question but
um if you really love somebody and you
intend for this life this relationship
to continue because if you don't there's
just going to breed resentment you're
going to find somebody else attractive
and partridge in a pear tree here's how
my wife has done it for me
um in the few seasons or 20 years when
I've just put on a bunch of weight and
I've gained 20 pounds doing this or
doing that
um
the weight is almost always the canary
in the coal mine it's almost always the
indicator that something in the
ecosystem is off
and she has sat down and said hey you
are snoring like crazy and that's not
who you normally are and you're always
tugging at your t-shirts now
um because they feel too tight I'm
always tugging at them tugging it I'm
tugging at them and so she can rattle
off three or four behaviors
that I know what the ultimate signal is
is that I'm out of control with my
eating or I'm using eating to soothe
something that's going on in my life or
whatever that happens to be
um and the fact that she loves me enough
to say there's a full picture here of my
husband that's not whole and I'm not
okay with that because I love you that's
very different than oh my God you got
fat I don't even want to I don't even
want to be with you anymore or God
you're lazy go to the gym that's one of
those gonna shut me down and one of
those is
all right I'm gonna get with somebody
because I know the answer good God I
work in this industry like I know the
answers but I need to get on the phone
to call somebody I'm gonna reach out I'm
gonna do whatever I need to do or I'm
just gonna suck it up start going to the
gym even though it's gonna be
uncomfortable for a few weeks until I
get the the thing going but it's rooted
in love and compassion not in judgment
and blame yeah it's all about how it's
delivered and the reasoning behind it
and like I said she knows yeah she's not
stupid she knows she's put weight on and
so brow beating her with it and telling
her how she should do it and what she
should do not helping
yeah it definitely for me it would be
harder to hear
just at the age that I am I you know
closer to like my teenage years and like
growing up I grew up in a household
where everything I ate was nitpicked how
I looked was nitpicked so it would be
hard to hear it
but if it came from a place of like love
and like in a way where it wasn't like
you're doing this like very derogatory
you know what I mean I think I could
understand it and cope with it I would
just need time gotcha gotcha we just
need time awesome which also is is I'll
leave it at this
when you're frustrated about something
like this something about your partner's
Aesthetics something about
um your partner's health
it is never a good idea to have that
conversation right then
it's not because everybody's charged up
you're charged up you're you're
emotional you're coming at it and
somebody who's struggling with any of
these issues is instantly going to
respond to that and so a lot of what
you've put on here fatigue exercise
weight lack of intimacy turning you
rejection turning you down a lot of
those things are all like
um a pie piece that you pull out one one
piece and the whole thing crumbles they
all work together on this thing uh they
all work in in sync together
um so
Dean here's how I would start this
conversation
I'm sorry
I can commit to you I can promise you
that over the last six months the last
year last two years
I've become judgmental
I've become short I've become frustrated
I become angry I've become all these
things you're my wife and I love you I'm
sorry
I'm worried about you
I've got my own struggles and my own
feelings and we can talk about those
things
but I need you to hear me say I'm sorry
most importantly I love you and I'm
worried about how tired you are all the
time
and I'm committed to being a part of
this family and to going all in I'm
going to cut back the time at the gym
I'm going to cut back time fixing cars
in the garage or playing guitar whatever
it is I'm going to be plugged into this
home
I'd love for you to go on a walk with me
at night if you want to need to go see a
counselor if you want to make some space
for being with friends but I feel like
I'm losing you to my phone or to your
phone I feel like I'm losing you to the
television I feel like I'm losing you to
Netflix
and I'm struggling with attraction
that's me being as honest as I can
and um I love you not going anywhere but
it would be dishonest if I told you I'm
not I'm not struggling with that too
start there
Dean you're gonna sit in front of your
wife and you're gonna hold up a mirror
to yourself and you're going to ascribe
to her what you see
and that's going to provide her
permission to say well this is how I
feel and this is how I've experienced to
you and this is what I'm going through
and from there y'all can create
something different Maybe
and if your wife's just a jerk then you
got to take that head on
but my guess is she's probably not
she's probably just done
and it's from that Ash that y'all can
plant something new that's gonna Bloom
and flower down the road hang in there
man